there's a growing interest in
fascination involving the topic of
Antarctica that far exceeds its
astounding landscapes and beauty and the
saying that space is the final frontier
well that's true but not quite yet
because let's not forget that we still
don't know what's underneath
Antarctica's nearly five and a half
million square miles of ice or fourteen
million square kilometres which is more
than a mile thick on average and even
exceeds three miles in thickness in
certain places in fact there are many
theories about Antarctica ranging from
lost ancient human civilizations that
may be hidden underneath the frozen ice
waiting to be discovered
to crashed UFOs and secrets alien UFO
bases and even curious questions as to
why various world political and
religious leaders have visited the
continent and in this video I'm going to
be connecting the dots on some really
interesting and even disturbing
information but first let me start off
by sharing some amazing details about
the Antarctica and continent itself for
example Antarctica is the fifth largest
continent and it's approximately the
size of the United States and Mexico
combined and it has an incredible water
volume of ice on top of it which equates
to approximately 6.4 million cubic miles
of water volume based on the most recent
and precise estimates and in fact if
this ice was to melt it would raise
global sea levels by approximately 190
feet or 58 meters Antarctica is also
considered a desert for the fact that it
receives less than two inches or 51
millimeters of rainfall every year and
the continent underneath the ice is
covered with mountain chains in fact the
highest mountain is Mount Vinson which
is approximately 16,000 feet or almost
5,000 meters above sea level and
something absolutely incredible it's
handed underneath the ice is a massive
trench formed by a glacier that's deeper
than the Grand Canyon
it's 1.9 miles deep and more than 15 and
a half miles across and in comparison
the Grand Canyon is just over a mile
deep or 1.8 kilometres in credible fact
is that it's the site of a massive
crater that's believed to be tied to the
worst mass extinction event ever this
crater is two-and-a-half times the size
of the Chicxulub crater
in Mexico that's believed to be the site
where the asteroid had wiped out the
dinosaurs to put it in perspective we're
talking this Wilkes land crater is 300
miles across we're in Mexico the
Chicxulub crater is about 110 miles
across however before Antarctica was
covered in ice they have found evidence
that dinosaurs once roamed Antarctica
and in fact the continent itself was
covered in force however life today
pretty much consists of penguins various
birds and other marine mammals such as
seals but headlines went around the
world just a few years ago when they
discovered that microbial life existed
and was thriving more than a half mile
underneath the Antarctic ice shelf which
completely shocked scientists what's
even crazier is that they believe that
Antarctica and North America were once
touching as they've identified through
matching rocks and this is from a
supercontinent dating before Pangaea
more than a billion years ago in
comparison to Pangaea which they believe
broke up about 175 million years ago now
diving into some of the other
interesting things about Antarctica that
you may have seen going around the
internet involves this tweet that
allegedly Buzz Aldrin had sent you know
the second man to walk on the moon who
visited an article last year and he was
medically evacuated for various health
issues with as long as I believed but
here's this tweet that he allegedly sent
out which reads we are all in danger it
is evil itself which of course has this
photo of a pyramid-shaped mountain
that's located in Antarctica but this is
completely fake it's been debunked it's
been proven as a total hoax he never
sent that but the mountain itself is
interesting and this is something that's
gained a lot of attention as many people
have speculated that there may be lost
ancient human civilization underneath
the ice and many people refer to this as
the Antarctica pyramid but upon a closer
inspection it's really not it's it's not
a pyramid I wish it was it's clearly
carved out of glaciers but something
that's look you know worth looking at
more closely if you compare it to the
Great Pyramid of Giza which has eight
sides most people are not aware of that
and it's only noticeable from the air
during dusk and dawn during the spring
and autumn equinoxes but when you look
at the photo again you can kind of see
one side of it seems to have that line
that could indicate possibly each sides
but is the other side you can see right
here you know it's just clearly
not it's just the mountain but there
have been many other things going around
the internet involving these ancient
human civilizations in Antarctica
possibly being the location of Atlantis
and perhaps it's buried underneath the
ice and there's been other photographs
and people look at Google Earth and
there's been some interesting things
here and it's like okay is there
something underneath you know this ice
or not is there something had humans
live there is the question that everyone
has and people seem to have a real
interest in this topic people seem to
have this gut instinct that maybe people
had lived there before so really what it
comes down to is how old is the ice on
top of Antarctica scientific researchers
have recently said that it's 20 million
years older than they had ever thought
and it's the ice first started forming
approximately 45 million years ago and
becoming the Antarctica we see today
about 34 million years ago but you know
when we talk about pole ships and I'm
gonna make a video on this entirely and
so in short we're talking about
geomagnetic pole shift which of course
the world is overdue by a few hundred
thousand years the last one was
approximately 780,000 years ago with a
minor one about forty-one thousand years
ago which some research has indicated
could have potentially been the reason
why the Neanderthals were wiped out
basically what it comes down to is Anna
geomagnetic pole shift the Earth's iron
core shifts and because of this our
compasses will be completely thrown off
and changed complete directions but the
earth itself doesn't just tip upside
down but when you think about how
earthquakes and volcanic activity are
dependent on shifting magma underneath
our Earth's surface is it possible that
during these pole shifts it can cause
some catastrophic changes in our
continents so when we consider how we
know that our continents are moving at
about an inch a year apart from each
other and we look at Pangaea okay 175
million years ago is it possible that
when the massive iron core that's
supposed to be at the center of our
planet when that shifts could that cause
some catastrophic quick movement and our
continents and if you think that's
far-fetched or ridiculous let's just
remind ourselves of the 2011 Japanese
earthquake and tsunami this earthquake
being a 9.0 was powerful enough to
change the tilt of the Earth's axis in
shortened Earth days by about 1.8
microseconds which might sound
negligible but it did it but furthermore
that earthquake moved the coast of
mainland Japan by 8 feet so we have to
open our minds to what's possible
involving pole ships and again I'll save
that for another video but simply my
point is this is it possible that some
of the ice in Antarctica isn't nearly as
old as what we thought it is now I
cannot make a video on Antarctica
without mentioning rothschild Island
that's right there's an island named
after the Rothschilds and if you're not
familiar the Rothschilds definitely look
into this family and the impact that
they have on or had on our global
economic society international banking
and the central banks that are put in
almost every single country throughout
the world and most people have no idea
who they are
I mean our whole system is made up of
rules that people created and no one
seems to know who created these rules
for our system I mean think about it
the rules didn't just come out of the
ground like flowers and bushes people
thought of this stuff and yet nobody
knows who our entire lives are based off
this current economic international
banking and central banking system and
almost nobody has any idea who started
it and who are the masterminds behind it
and I mean I have a Masters of Business
Administration and they sure didn't
teach anything about this I mean the
money that we have today fiat money is
no different than monopoly money it's
not based on anything and people don't
question it so when you look at actual
quote say from mayor Rothschild permit
me to issue and control the money of a
nation and I care not who makes its laws
and his son Nathan Rothschild went on to
say I care not what puppet is placed
upon the throne of England to rule the
Empire on which the Sun never sets the
man who controls British money supply
controls the British Empire and I
control the British money supply so it's
worth mentioning and if you think that
I'm getting kind of off-topic here then
he also mentioned the Rockefellers who
had a huge impact and you may have heard
about them both before but I think the
younger demographic probably is
completely unaware of the influence that
they their family had on our society
today and it just so happens that what
you look at it the Rockefeller mountains
named after john d rockefeller and if
you're curious go ahead and read this
quote that john d rockefeller said
himself press pause so you can have time
to read it but let me keep going for the
sake of brevity and by the way there are
so many different theories and
conspiracies out there involving the
Rothschilds so leave
if you have any insights on this stuff
it's very taboo it seems like to mention
these people but I thought it was worth
mentioning because some geographical
land features and Antarctica are named
after them so well there's that now
other interesting things that you may
have heard about Antarctica there's been
various conspiracies involving secret
Nazi alien bases and UFOs but in my
research I think that most of this stuff
is just made up again I don't pretend to
have all the answers if you have insight
and information please leave a comment
and share it with all of us but what I
can tell you is that Hitler had
established a base called new Swabia he
wanted to set up a whaling station
because their economy was dependent on a
lot of it for soap and other things and
so look into that
I just not so sure that it involves
aliens or anything else but and again on
somebody that do believe that does
believe that aliens are actively
visiting Earth so take it for what it's
worth but something that is absolutely
real is something that's referred to as
Operation Paperclip and this is not a
conspiracy you can read about this on
CIA gov and this was secret for a very
long time I don't remember what year I'd
have to double-check when this was
Declassified but more than 1,600 Nazi
scientists after World War two were
taken to the United States and given
jobs with the government and the
Russians received who knows how many
others some Nazi scientists many people
don't know this because they don't teach
it in school but one of these scientists
was Wernher von Braun who was an SS
scientist and you can see him here and
look at the people that he frequented
with you might recognize someone up
there in the front and he went on become
a major player in NASA director ER and
actually the creator and architect of
the Saturn 5 rocket which sent
astronauts to the moon this guy was a
big deal and for many years people had
no idea that he worked at a factory and
I believe Berlin where the slowest
Jewish worker was hung outside of this
Factory and he worked there and the Sian
Simon Wiesenthal Center said that if he
was still alive today he would be
charged as a Nazi war criminal and most
people have no idea that this is the guy
that created the Saturn 5 rocket for us
to go to the moon and if you're
wondering by the way how this ties to
Antarctica well Wernher von Braun and
top NASA management went to Antarctica
in the 60s in preparation for the Apollo
missions
and without a doubt the reason for the
Cold War in the first place
as well as the reason why I never turned
into a war is because of Operation
Paperclip Russians in the United States
both got incredibly brilliant scientists
and who knows what side was able to
develop what type of weaponry because of
it but to keep this going many people
have wondered why various leaders
throughout the world have visited an
article and in fact the highest ranking
US official to visit Antarctica is John
Kerry who went there on get this
Election Day 2016 it was really
suspicious how this was reported on he
went on to say that oh yeah I'm here
researching a climate change and that's
why I'm here but there was many
different theories about this people you
know claims that oh he's visiting
secrets UFO bases that have been
discovered under the ice all kinds of
different claims I think the most likely
explanation is that he was getting a
free trip on the taxpayer dollar he
traveled all over the world I think more
than any other official ever had he
loves to travel and I think that really
what it comes down to is that's why he
was there if you have any other
information about this again leave a
comment but if you want to know the
reason why so many countries have
interests in article and I have to
mention the Antarctica treaty which was
signed back in 1959 which involves seven
different countries which has since gone
on to involve more than 53 and these
countries have bases in fact there's
more than 68 bases or 68 I should say on
Antarctica and believe it or not the
United States is has the central
territory which touches all the other
country's territory so go figure on that
but if you want to know what no one else
is talking about virtually no one the
real interesting Antarctica I believe
besides on who knows what's underneath
the ice well there are some things we do
know that most people are not aware of
for one thing oil it's believed that
there's more than 200 billion barrels of
oil underneath the ice or the continent
of Antarctica which would put it at the
third highest oil reserves in the entire
planet some people say this isn't true
if you look at the Antarctic and
Southern Ocean coalition they say that
this is just speculation not backed up
by actual study and they don't believe
it but I would say like wait don't don't
be so naive what do you think all these
countries are doing down there and
pretend you know what they're doing this
is a huge area of space you know in
Antarctica again the size of the United
States and Mexico so if you think that
these countries and these companies that
are down there doing all this research
aren't looking into this stuff and doing
things on the down-low well I think that
they are and since again we know about
the force and dinosaurs being in
Antarctica it's fair to say that there
is oil under that ground but even more
significant or a significant I should
say is the fact that they've established
that there are quote huge deposits
amounts of diamonds located in
Antarctica and it's not just diamonds
either they have resources including
silver gold copper nickel platinum
cobalt which of course is used in all
these electric batteries and cars even
uranium so think about that so when you
consider again that there are 68 bases
and 53 countries that are there you can
start to connect the dots on the
significance of Antarctica and what
we're looking at here is essentially the
grand global strategy all of these
countries are knowing that someday that
ice is gonna melt it might not be in our
lifetimes but you know what they are
prepping for it and I soon suspect that
they're gonna start digging for it even
if it's against the treaty which isn't
due for renewal and voting until 2048
but it is worth mentioning that various
militaries are on the Antarctica
territory itself and even though they're
not supposed to according to the treaty
but Chile and an Argentina particularly
have actual standing army presence there
but they claim that oh this is for
scientific research so it's a loophole
think about all that oil and the
Diamonds and who knows what else might
be underneath that ice and it starts to
make sense anyways I'm absolutely going
to have to make future videos in
Antarctica because there are too many
other topics that I can't include all in
one video and again definitely leave a
comment share any knowledge or insight
that you have into this topic or
anything that I've discussed here or
left out but I'm Jimmy this is Brian in
sight hit like and subscribe and I have
many other videos to come and a whole
wide variety of topics take care
everybody